[Music]
this is star talk I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson here your personal astrophysicist
and today we have a hybrid episode we've
got a special guest who's an expert in
survival oh my gosh we're gonna find out
all about that
and then we're gonna pivot to Cosmic
queries on that subject because we know
people think about that my co-host Gary
Riley Gary man all right forward soccer
pro soccer announcer and we got him we
share him with the rest of the soccer
universe and Chuck Nice Chuck that's
right former survivalist
let me just set the record straight here
okay I am a black man of a certain age
different kind of survivalist in America
I'm still standing
fabulous okay okay that's a different
kind of survivalist oh yeah well let's
find out so Gary set us up here and tell
us this all right um a little while ago
we had a question in one of our Cosmic
queries about how would an understanding
of Science in a Wilderness survival
situation
be good and you know we're not talking
Survivor we're talking kind of alone the
one that airs on the History Channel is
that the naked people
they can that's the other one that's
naked oh that's that's naked and alone I
don't know so I mean if you're if you're
unaware
with slightly closed and alone right who
can tough it out for about a hundred
days in the middle or somewhere nowhere
yeah nothing but some serious survival
skills from from memory our answer
wasn't the best yeah so I I went to show
where is there one called uh fully
clothed or overdressed and and with good
company that's any of any one of the
housewives franchise right on okay go
ahead sorry man all right so um we
needed a proper expert a real survival
expert and uh today's guest is Dr
timojin Tan founder and owner of
survival doctors practicing medical
doctor in Owen Sound Ontario that'll be
in Canada served in the Canadian Armed
Forces specializing in Arctic Warfare
and survival yeah
okay you know that's got to be a thing
when you're from Canada
we know I mean you also the skill set
here involves survival medicine disaster
medicine and Disaster Response awesome
um
is this like glaciers or chasing you
down the valley
we're gonna find out polar bears right
Gary finish finish finish all right um
he was in series nine of the alone
series Survival series that airs on the
History Channel first of all
timogintan MD
what's Arctic Warfare all about please
welcome to StarTalk yes okay go ahead
thank you
thank you guys so um cold weather
Warfare Arctic Warfare is the practice
of any Warfare in cold environments so
that may be in the Arctic sub-arctic or
just in your back yard if there's an
invasion and there's a cold weather so
you have to battle the elements
logistically
move your troops between and uh know how
to do assaults win Wars um in cold
environments so now you know the
biathlon came out of Arctic Warfare and
do you guys train that way too are you
on skis and shooting and all that kind
of stuff everything that you would do in
regular combat you're doing it also like
for snow Sports
I wish we had Seas that'd make us move a
lot faster but uh snowshoes a big old
goopy Snowshoe yeah tennis rackets 100
pounds on us carrying 200 pounds on a
sled
wow the history of our species before
agriculture was primarily during the Ice
Age and so when I think of survival they
survived because we're here today so did
you learn anything from whatever the the
books tell us about caveman survival
versus what you might pick up in a
modern 21st century understanding of
survival I mean a lot of the physiology
in our bodies are the same people go
through severe hypothermia at around
three hours of uh too hot or too cold so
too cold in this situation and the
layering systems and waterproofing and
shelters those Concepts don't really
change maybe the climate the landscape
the Predators do change and the tools
that we had so I would say that the
average person who survives multiple
Winters way back when was a much
stronger and more formidable person than
someone today with all these
Technologies
Chuck he just said that the winters
killed off everybody else
that's basically yeah yeah and exactly
so here's the deal though
um when you're when you're
survival there are certain things that
we need to survive okay number one being
water
and the second like you just mentioned
is you know hypothermia in either way
right you know so hyper hypothermia so
how do you get fire
how do you if if everything's frozen how
do you get your water you know all these
things are just almost impossible just
because everything is Frozen
and if you drop most of us butt naked
into the Arctic we're dead you know a
few hours later so I'm dead before you
drop me because I killed myself on the
way
yeah
just to start off uh you mentioned water
you mentioned cold one thing that people
often forget is oxygen so without oxygen
you're done in three minutes so
oftentimes that's um
Overlook because we think about uh we
take that for granted but is there an
emergency if they're an absence of
oxygen up in Canada
what am I missing so if we think about
it um oxygen environmental right we can
be at altitude we could be in the in a
cave but more realistically in our
day-to-day if it's a medical issue if
you have a heart attack if you're
bleeding out these are things that are a
priority over your survival priorities
because that medical condition will kill
you in minutes instead of hours all
right we are able to survive you know a
couple of days at least get over the
first what do you call it drop shock
um yep what is your don't leave home
without it item or short group of things
that you well I ain't going anywhere
with that this love I'm going with an
airplane or snowmobile
just Gary before you before we go to
that question I just want to I want to
add some some emphasis to what Dr Tan
just told us you can rank
in sequence what you will die from if
you are if it is withheld from you right
and so I I gotta be all in with you on
this uh uh timogen that that if without
oxygen you're you're dead in however
many minutes minutes without blood
you're dead so they learned in Vietnam
most of the servicemen who died didn't
die from getting shot they got they died
from the loss of blood in the womb for
having been shot and so the first thing
you do is stop the bleeding that's the
first thing okay forget everything else
stop the bleeding because you will die
from that faster than anything else so
I'd like to hear more about this
sequence this death sequence that you
want to protect yourself against
absolutely so the death sequence that
sounds so ominous it sounds so Neil
that's what it says it sounds so Neil
deGrasse Tyson
so the death sequence it starts with
three minutes without oxygen three hours
without normal thermia too hot or too
cold right then it's three days without
water three weeks without food
um and then after weeks and people often
forget this and neglect this and it
happens from moment one two moment
multiple months is three months without
companionships connections or
relationships so psychologically that
could uh be a huge effect because people
do people go mad or do they actually die
because we're the other things you said
result in death I mean for me three
months without being around anybody
because I have three kids I call that a
vacation
that's a beautiful thing that's
wonderful yeah and and even Legend of
alone I used to think that too and I
remembered I I I grew up with heavy
doses of The Twilight Zone which
predated our time and space but it knew
it was imminent and many of the episodes
studied loneliness in space it assumes
somehow we would send one astronaut to
Mars right or whatever which never
happened of course plus NASA's always
yapping at you on the on the rich on the
on the channels but the the they they
all went crazy and I thought wow and
then when as I got older I got to Echo
what Chuck said here not only do I
greatly relish time alone I know people
who don't ever want to talk to anybody
ever you give them books or their music
and they're fine so who is it really
true that three months without human
contact is for some people is bad I I
can't I don't see that it really depends
on the person like you said some people
need to be alone want to be alone
and for those people maybe that could be
an option for them
um I would say for the majority of
people especially if we just look at the
pandemic as an example and then look at
the incidents across the U.S uh for
mental the rising mental illness we see
that disconnect from people can cause
disturbances what did it happen to you
because you were on that alone show
except how long could you be if there's
a camera on your ass all the time solo
cabs so that's that that's the big thing
all of alone is self-film the b-roll
that's done at different sites but it's
all self-film it's you and your three
buddy cameras and you can name them if
you want to but though that's your
relationship okay that that means it's
getting really bad if you start naming
your cameras yeah yeah when your
camera's uh played a role of Wilson you
know you've been out here too long too
long so it does make sense because
um there is a great deal of research now
some of which I found very intriguing
about solitary confinement uh being
considered torture and by the way what
they don't say in solitary confinement
is you're not only in solitary
confinement you're in a tiny volume so
there's a size area thing but you're out
in the wilderness so you don't have the
volume problem the area of the range you
got the range but but did you feel this
emotionally though I'll I'll give you uh
what I what I did as a trick because I
worked with my patients in a family
medicine setting
um I also um been to therapy myself and
a lot of the people I work with in the
medical field are psychiatrists
therapists cognitive behavioral neural
therapists so I threw the kitchen sink
at this whole experience and did all the
coping mechanisms I've ever been taught
just tried to be uh as good as I can
with that aspect and one of the things
that I really emphasized is finding ways
to build relationships with what I got
so that maybe naming my cameras are you
friends with animals okay so do me a
favor because I'm I am so this is
probably
this is so fascinating the fact that you
spent first of all how how long was it
that you were alone and then second
question follow-up what were your top
three coping mechanisms because you said
you know you you did everything from
family therapy to your psychiatrist or
psychologists so what are the top three
and how long were you alone
so I was alone for uh 63 days and uh
yeah yeah it was quite some time over
there that's all the seasons change but
one of the the categories of coping
mechanisms that I use is should be
differentiated between drop shock and
initial stuff or acute kind of reactions
and what I did on the long term
for a lot of the initial things I did uh
breathing exercises same thing I did in
the the military for shooting actually
to elevate that parasympathetic nerve
response so bearing down box breathing
get really chill so I can have a clear
head
um and then I did a lot of meditation on
the acute setting on the long term
setting
um it was for me how do I make a
connection how do I build a relationship
on the land that I am on um especially
if it's indigenous land how do I build
that relationship with no one there and
um one of the things that I practice a
lot was gratitude and asking for help
openly asking for help and one of the to
the cameras
to whatever was out there okay I got you
go ahead go for it and I think it's
called delusional he's crossed over
delusion Illusions yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah after week two for sure so I think
a powerful feeling is that when you ask
for something whether that's your
ancestors the spirits of the woods or
God right and you receive that right
that's an incredibly empowering feeling
that you know that someone has your back
and when you do it once you do it twice
you do it three times and you do it
almost every day and you receive and you
receive and you receive so it's a
manifestation and some people would call
that prayer and they're thinking that's
a higher power that's actually granting
it some people call it manifesting which
is why uh it's just speaking things into
existence you're not literally speaking
them into existence but the fact that
you verbalize it that you hear it uh
allows you to then manifest it you're
actually doing it but you wouldn't be
able to do it unless you spoke it some
people as you said your ancestors so
they're they're I mean throughout
history there's been so many things
associated with that but I'm that is
fascinating that you actually put that
into practice
so timogen how how quickly do you get to
suffer mentally right in isolation
because this can't be good this can't be
good news
get to the good stuff tell us when you
started breaking down come on so okay
you know you're in isolation probably
not the best thing as we've just
discussed but you've compounded that
with terrorific deprivation now surely
you really are putting yourself on a
fast track to having some disturbance
there
absolutely and let me tell you
starvation is no joke you know um
one of the worst pains that you can kind
of feel especially when you transition
between starvation and actually craving
because your stomach shrinks you're not
as hungry a little bit of food satisfies
you but when you start craving things
and you can't get it I was craving
things that I I would never eat the
yellow orange cheese at the corner shop
that you dip your nachos in yeah but I
was craving that and it's not even real
cheese it's not even real cheese that's
his point right
so you get into that craving Zone it's
like an obsession and a pain that you
can't really touch and uh I would say
that's another form of um of torture but
when you think about when my suffering
uh first started was after I didn't have
a plan you know you go in you have 10
items you think you know what you're
gonna do with your shelter with your
food sources right you go there and you
get whatever resources that the land
offers I caught a few fish first two
days that's amazing every every cast I
threw there were bites day four nothing
day five nothing two weeks nothing I
don't think so there was only four fish
that I caught out in the first few days
you overfished the land with only four
fish it was only four fish no the
producer put the four fish in at the
beginning
when you when you're in this isolation
but this mental aspect effect of
survival and isolation is fascinating I
think we would all agree with that
does your brain now engage with kind of
upgrading your senses now are you you
know that much more aware there's this
survival Instinct really really kick in
a hundred percent so there is an
instinct that isn't it too I think all
humans uh that are open to that type of
experience if you don't break down and
you are in it to live another day
whether that's another day or to win
have a million dollars if you are
invested in it
um your attention does shift and it is
uh quite a beautiful thing because it's
almost like a constant grounding
meditative uh experience where you're
sensing with your nose your feelings
your your your your sound your case like
every little sense and every little
sound in the woods whether that's a
squirrel sound or a bird that you've
never heard before you get to know every
little thing and it became like almost a
research project for me because I was
associating different sounds to
different behaviors of different animals
at different times of the day and as I
got more data I was able to hunt more
effectively so after two weeks I'm not
getting any animal protein after some
observations and taking some methyl
notes I only took shots that I knew I
could get at 100 or close to it and uh I
was hunting for the first time because
prior to this experience I had never
hunted I've shot a recurve bow for seven
years but I never hunted before so
animal protein that's a code for dead
for for dead meat
I'll start craving it I mean so so this
craving concept uh there was a scene
forgive my cinematic reference here but
in what's that movie with the Central
Park animals go to Madagascar or
Madagascar Madagascar there you go in
Madagascar all these animals were
coexisting in the Central Park Zoo and
they're all being fed daily so they're
just friends then they end up in
Madagascar and the lion
is hungry
and all of a sudden the zebra who I
think was played by Chris Rock is that
right yeah the zebra
who was his friend started looking like
a pork chop or something or some kind of
slab of meat in Italian
so it wouldn't be pork should be a zebra
chop but but that that was a hint at the
psychological shift of what previously
you would never consider eating now
looks delectable so did insects start
looking good to you and other things
that you just would never consider
eating oh
insects I wish I had insects because I
would have eaten it but it was so cold
by week two that there were not insects
up to like three feet deep because I was
digging for it for things
um but there are parts of animals that I
never thought I would eat that I ended
up enjoying and craving grains spinal
cords eyeballs you name it I was trying
to eat like up to 90 of most animals
that I would take out there because you
were that hungry and and and and you
cooked them though right you you oh yeah
okay I don't know anything about listen
man this is the you are speaking an
alien language to me right now because
if it does not come from Whole Foods I
feel like I am hunting okay
plus if I'm gonna be eating somebody's
eyeball I'm gonna have to cook them
first right oh yeah season it a little
bit okay so if we stay on this mental
thing
do we now get to hallucination oh do we
now get to especially in the Hunger
State yes you get now you talked about
indigenous land
do you then kind of absorb some of this
spirituality and then reconnect with
ancestral does it come on like that or
am I beginning to trip
I think it's a little different for
everyone I can only speak to my
experience out there and since I was
actively trying to connect with uh those
spirits of lands those ancestors of the
lands and asking for help because I'm no
Hunter
um I was asking hey where do I find food
how do I get food what would be the best
shelter
um and there was subtle signs of uh
presence there so there have been um the
way trees are bent there to make cooking
benches and stuff like that so to see
that to feel that
um and then to gain from the land it did
feel like I was surrounded by that type
of presence and that was incredibly
comforting to me
so it's a very powerful mental Force
operating on you because you know we we
in modern science of course we we poo
poo all of that but if you're out alone
and you need to survive the fact that
you had those thoughts at all and the
fact that those thoughts are especially
prevalent in among native peoples of
land pre-historic times then you must
you are tapping into something that must
go very deep within our species yeah it
makes sense I think so and timid are you
um in any way uh as far as your ancestry
connected to uh indigenous people for
this part of the world you know native
not this part of the world but um I
would say that I'm named after Genghis
Khan so I'm probably
in some way uh related to a bunch of
different people genetically because of
that how are you named after game man
we're all related
my boy had some children coming out of
here wait wait how is uh timogen tan
named after Genghis Khan
Genghis Khan is a title right um he was
given that name his name was timujin
which uh meant of iron so typically
given to family members who were
destined to be blacksmith
yeah so he became a child slave Who Rose
up against his oppressors and just took
over a big portion of the world never
stopped um yeah never stopped yeah he
never said he broke everything I know
about Genghis Khan was is from Bill and
Ted's Excellent Adventure
[Laughter]
I'm being honest see here I'm being
honest with you
all right we gotta take a quick break
when we come back fascinating yeah oh my
gosh we're going to return to our
conversation with timogintan and we're
gonna learn uh more about what he did
was it a bit of instinct or was it a bit
of science that he brought to his
survival when Star talk sports edition
Cosmic queries hybrid continues
we're back start talking this episode is
on staying alive
I work so hard on myself man look at
what you do
some you got there Neil oh dear we
got temujin ton did I pronounce it your
full name correctly Tim man like a
suntan Tan Tan Tam tan thank you for
correcting me here so no problem you
were alone for two months surviving
and you have a knowledge of physiology
being a medical doctor you also have
knowledge of science related to that
science of an environment so could you
could you walk us through
uh the steps of starvation which did you
you experienced some of that did you not
I think everyone on the history of alone
has experienced starvation to one extent
or the other and uh it is a very precise
um and predictable sequence of events
[Laughter]
absolutely so you have um glucose in
your blood right so your body prepares
that your brain prefers one of the many
sugars one of the simple sugars
exactly so that becomes depleted within
the first day or so uh then your body
kicks in to uh glycogen breakdown so
your liver and your muscles start
breaking down the storage package so
that you have more glucose right within
three or four days depending on your
body habits and your Baseline makeup uh
that's gone so four days uh you need
another source of fuel right and your
body starts to break down both proteins
and fat right and then soon after that
preparentially focusing on fat that's
kind of uh what ketosis is mainly about
so the breakdown of fat and the
breakdown products of that just to be
clear when someone says on a keto diet
they're on a diet that puts their body
into that state is that correct of
ketosis absolutely yeah
so a few things happen to you you feel
like you're run down low energy your
breath and your your mouth may feel
different so I felt like my mouth was
really dry and just tasted different
some people say that their breath smells
a little more sweet but I didn't smell
anything different
but after that stage you can pretty much
crew so you feel really really crummy
for a few days a few weeks even and then
your body starts getting used to that
energy source and even though you may be
getting some carbs from berries from
from little things that you're foraging
it's not enough to pull you out of
ketosis unless you find like a jackpot
of like a bunch of things
so like like a stack of pancakes around
the background yeah okay yeah did you
did you call it you find a
superintendent in the woods yeah did you
call it cruising
you cruise this keto state
yeah so um I imagine that's when people
who do ketosis for fun or for health
queries
um they they typically feel bad at the
beginning but then learn to work with it
they learn how to exercise with it and
then they're able to function and that's
true in the starvation State as well
um so after I felt like I couldn't walk
more than a few steps at a time before
feeling a little winded or lightheaded
then I was hunting
um like multiple hours a day no problem
um but the scary thing is once your fat
reserves go down because I packed about
30 pounds on my frame and once that was
all gone it starts to take from your
organ fat and once that's all gone your
body senses the amount of fatty acids in
your blood and there's a critical level
that it reaches until your engine that's
uh saying what fuel you need to take
which is very drastically to protein and
you'll notice a very aggressive take of
protein off your frame and we're talking
about noticing function loss gradual and
substantial function loss within within
a span of days
it's the eating itself eating it's
eating itself eating itself literally
your muscles are atrophying not from
lack of use but from your body like
stripping them of yeah um you know
source of energy so as a sources
you've bulked up you've
you know you've you've put on the lumber
30 pounds before you go out so wow and
how long does it take for you to hit
that strip mining phase it gives you it
gives you a little bit of time so
depending on what you're doing in a loan
you're building your shelter right
you're not you're not sleeping in a tent
or anything like that so the first few
weeks is pretty energy intense
um I would expect
you would lose about anywhere from a
half a pound if you weren't doing a
whole lot to a pound and a half a day
for the first few weeks and then
afterwards it's it kind of evens out
when you get into your groove where
you're just like sitting fishing
checking traps uh expect a pound to half
a pound a day of loss no matter what you
do
so if you're just laying around in your
sleeping bag you might be losing half a
pound a day that's crazy well you're a
metabolic rate you're trying to maintain
your body temperature especially against
low temperatures that takes more energy
than it otherwise would so you're not
just you're never not burning nothing
I just forgot about the fact that we're
in the cold when we're doing this right
which exacerbates everything yeah
everything oh
and I said you're never not burning
nothing is that to have too many no
that's that's a triple negative you went
there you came back and then you came
back again I came back out safely
Timmy are you in that position of luxury
to store things like could you store any
food stuff could you store water or is
it you know what I'll take it and I've
got no way in a pantry yeah did you have
a Pantry in your storage area no
actually I did have a little Pantry
um and I used uh reindeer Moss so it's a
lichen
um and it's a lichen that has fiber it's
a lichen that has uh some simple amino
acids and a low amount of carbs and
sugars
raid your Moss what is it's a very it's
uh it kind of looks like a little fluffy
thing not not a moss not a mushroom uh
something in between so a lichen so I
had about 15 pounds of that in my
shelter and I made a big old basket to
keep it in and to dry it when I looked
at some of the contestants the that were
involved in the alone series and there's
been a number of series
they're not all just being airlifted out
because they're lonely some of them
being an airlifted out because
they've got something tainted be it
water be it food stuff so how how are
you how are you going about I mean you
plus plus here you're a medical doctor
but how are you coping if you're not
able to get potable water if you're not
able to do anything but drink stuff
that's got the wrong yeah one one bad
encounter with the wrong bacteria and
goodbye it's over
absolutely and if you look at season
nine of Alone
um about 40 of the contestants got some
kind of gastric bug namely giardi I
think was the biggest culprit because
they were hunting beavers and it only
takes two cysts so two cysts under a
microscope to get infected so hygiene if
you have a good idea of how to keep your
Camp clean and uh and practice good
hygiene that goes a long way so don't
eat don't eat the singers is what you're
saying well you can you can eat Beaver
just make sure that you're not using a
beaver tail as your plate which I think
someone did and got really sick
I get all this it's man against nature
man against the elements but how about
man against
polar bear you're in the ark how do you
it's not clear to me how you would ever
win against a polar bear without a 30
ought 6. 30 odd six would be great okay
but if you see a polar bear it's not
because you stumbled upon and by
happenstance he has been tracking you
that guy has a huge sniffer so that
amount of muscle and pure feral ferocity
you don't really stand a chance without
um kind of modern weapons you can try to
shoot an arrow at him but that thing if
he charges you and hits you one time
you're pretty much done you're done I
can't speak to the veracity but a male
polar bears can smell female polar bears
from miles and miles away and I maybe
that's part of to help with the mating
process I'm not sure but if they have
that strong a sense of smell I'm I'm
sure that food You're Gonna smell your
ass yeah no it is right up there
you have food sex and shelter two three
things
yeah yeah okay so you're saying you're
admitting you need modern weapons you're
admitting that
I would say so unless you have a tribe
but okay but most survivalist booklets
and things are more sort of who's the
guy who did everything with duct tape
and and oh MacGyver MacGyver yeah yeah
yeah so MacGyver doesn't have fancy
weapons he's he's resourceful with
what's around him but you're saying in
your situation there are occasions where
being resourceful would never
uh uh improve your survival
you would be you would have to be pretty
darn resourceful to make a bomb or
something like that a huge trap for a
polar bear okay yeah hitting him with a
snowball's not gonna do it huh no it
won't not gonna happen huh yeah all
right so so let's get to our Cosmic
queries let's maybe slip one in before
our second break so who's got the first
one all right I'll jump in uh this one
from our patreon listeners and thank you
there's some fantastic questions Aaron
Rosenberg Victor Frankl wrote in Man's
Search for meaning that when we are no
longer able to change a situation we are
challenged to change ourselves Dr 10
with this and your experiences in mind
what was a survival situation that
surprised you the most in terms of
digging deep and confronting yourself
and then this flips and how might these
lessons we've learned from survival in
extreme conditions here on Earth be
applied to long-term space travel or
future extraterrestrial colonies oh wow
with this
is how or when and what circumstance
would we change ourselves to overcome an
incredible adversity perhaps that
adversity is being alone specifically in
space and I think the flip for me is
after I got some more food after my
shelter was cozy I was hanging out by
the fire
um the next question was why am I still
there you know uh what was my purpose
what was my mission
um at that point and I remember there's
a specialist at that point wow yeah
exactly
and I think a lot of people get that
um when they're alone and they don't
really have a clear reason to be there
or to push forward and for me
um I actively was searching for that
reason and on day 40 I remember just
watching the river and having a memory
pop up and it was a memory of uh
something that my mom had told me when I
was a kid
and that got me thinking about how my
mom has
um been through the past year and how
far away I I have been from her from
Medical School from traveling and so
forth she told me she told me that uh
whatever I did as long as I love doing
it and as long as I tried to be the best
at it that she'd be proud of me oh yeah
and she was the type of woman that would
fight for any of her kids no matter what
and
um she went through a bunch of health
issues relationship issues Financial
issues through the days
um and years and just became a person
who was not that person I knew when I
was five years old okay and do wow to
potentially have a purpose out there to
say hey maybe I can remind her that to
show her the type of person she raised
the values that she bestowed upon me
maybe that would make something click so
that she can go back to that person or
even think that she deserves to be that
person wow is that what pushed that's
what pushed me and I think
that is yeah a spiritual pep talk right
well that is yeah from Beyond right but
you know what it's like it's a spiritual
um um it's it's spiritual in nature but
it is also so inexorably Tethered to
what is corporeal that it is it's kind
of a mind just put those three words to
inexorably Tethered to the corporeal
what's wrong with it those three words
just come out of your mouth in a row yes
they did why okay okay all right is that
bad no no I guess not sorry my
vocabulary and I'm ready for that okay
okay what I'm saying is it's kind of a
you kind of it's a mind F in a way you
know what I'm saying but it's but that's
how deep it is like what you don't
that's not something you would have
thought of taking a bubble bath is what
I'm saying
and let me address the space side of
that question I mean we're we're in a
position the space Voyage just trick it
out with whatever you want get the
Netflix account you know the the music I
so I don't see that as a problem
traveling to a destination but when you
get there then all of what you're saying
would matter if you're sort of a I mean
what do you call the first ones if
you're the first ones coming in Pioneers
it's settlers Pioneers yeah you'll need
some of that but on on the voyage just
trick out the spaceship in whatever way
you need it to be what another thing
before we take a break you commented
earlier
about that you started naming things and
having conversations with things that's
a recurring theme in at least four films
that portray the last person on Earth
so in the Omega Man I Am Legend
um and then there's another film which
lesser known the World the Flesh and the
devil which actually had had Harry
Belafonte in it and there was an Aussie
film actually a New Zealand film uh
called quiet Earth all of those there's
a person who thinks they're the last one
on Earth but that they're in cities
right and so they go into like shopping
stores you know uh department stores and
they make friends with the mannequins
mannequins wow the mannequins all have
names say how you doing today they dress
them differently what's up witty yeah I
know exactly
so that's exactly what you're describing
and I'm thinking man this is getting
deep inside what the human brain wants
to do maybe civilization is squashing
that in some fundamental way you need to
Let's more that out maybe life would be
more interesting and more fun we got to
take a break when we come back more
Cosmic queries talk
[Music]
we're back start talk Cosmic queries
we're talking about how to survive man
Wilderness me this is so much deeper
than I thought it would have did
tan who's a survivalist also a medical
doctor and he he appeared in and it was
a contestant in series nine of alone on
the History Channel where you got you
carry your own cameras you're gonna
follow by a camera person that then you
wouldn't be alone right you plus a
camera you're alone you got your own
cameras so this is fast every bit of
this is fascinating and it is something
I will clearly never do in my life so so
yeah all right so Gary uh Chuck you got
some questions from her yeah before we
picture our fan base before we do it can
I just give five dollars right now so I
can ask a question
[Laughter]
because here's what I want to know
our talk coffee all right we're gonna
put this in the in the in the bin all
right put it in okay everything that
we've talked about so far has been so
intense mentally how how did they screen
you how did they know that hey I'm not
gonna screw this guy up for the rest of
his life by letting him go and try this
yeah so the screening process is I think
standard for a lot of TV things you get
a medical check from a doctor and that's
pretty much it if you don't get the
history of it any kind of mental illness
then that's up to you too to try but if
you do then another word to do this in
other words you signed a release that's
right answers
all right give me another question who's
got it uh Ronnie Wayne gortz from
Brooklyn in New York he says doctors
Tyson and tan and Mr Nice what are the
best practices to optimize the design of
shelters clothing and equipment for
individuals facing a wide range of
extreme conditions and would having a
knowledge in fluid dynamics or Material
Science give you the edge in survival
yeah more broadly science in general
because you know the cavemen didn't have
science but they they managed to birth
all of us right eventually so how much
does science matter
So Silent science when you look at uh
you're talking about blue Dynamics I'll
talk about fluid dynamics in the body
and also concepts of insulation how do
we retain heat
so we know that heat is lost by multiple
different means so if you kind of halt
those multiple different means by
insulating having vapor barriers to
prevent evaporation and con and
convection that's super helpful and
wicking away for your body so the water
is not retained close to your body so
you're not changing the water
temperature and transferring that energy
from your body's heat to elevate that
temperature in that water so that from a
science standpoint is there but very
succinctly and simply insulate yourself
have a vapor barrier if possible have a
layer that reflects heat as well and
also have a way to do that in all parts
of your body make sure as as much as
possible cover up so in Arctic
temperatures all you're seeing is like
too little little holes for your
nostrils and that's it everything else
is covered up in at least three
different layers
um and when you're looking at your
shelter you want an insulating and
waterproof layer that's at least a foot
thick My Shelter later on alone with
about two and a half feet thick of moss
dirt and ice
so warm and dry is what you want yeah
yeah
insulated warm and dry basically that's
that's the rule of thumb okay so there
would have been igloo
igloos are awesome because again uh
they're insulated
um and they're thick so most igloos are
at least a foot and a half to two feet
thick and you're just trapping a lot of
your own body heat and uh if you're not
starving and you have a lot of
um a lot of calories that you're just
burning off that heat a lot of that heat
is retained in that structure didn't
know that okay yeah so you can heat up
an igloo uh or like a 10 foot by 10 foot
with like two candle and have enough to
not need a jacket
damn
yeah okay very efficient very efficient
barbecue weather
all right Chuck you got a question uh
this is still figure seven steel finger
seven says hello Neil Dr Tan hello Gary
how long can a human survive without
water
and how long can a human survive
drinking only their own urine I'm asking
for a friend
that's funny yeah because you said three
days but I I was remembering more like a
week without water isn't that
um so three days is typically your your
marker but let's say if you're in a
desert or if you are lost and you are
already dehydrated that timeline gets
pushed a little shorter
um so three days without water is
typical your guidelines still work
around if you're conserving a lot
um and not doing much you can extend it
a little bit but um what about eating
your own drinking your own pee which we
hear done yeah people do that that is
not advisable because that will um make
you a little more dehydrated and help
accumulate a lot of the toxins that is
the waste product in your urine in your
body so not advisable if you can distill
it just like how we do that right that
would be an excellent choice and with
some simple tools a few buckets
um things that you can carve you can
make improvised distillation setup in
the woods too right yeah okay so that's
that's the idea of the drinking the
piece like what are those suits in Doom
that they wear that have the yeah
yeah
it's kind of cool all right there you go
okay keep going who's got the next one
all right I'll jump in you guys never
share the questions with me just you
know take it easy put your feet up uh
this is from Nick Smith another one of
our patreon listeners uh during the tail
end of a few crimes in the mountains
where my partner and I have been moving
for over 24 hours both of us have
experienced hallucinations
um I always assumed they're from some
combination of exhaustion and running on
a calorie deficit I'm curious however if
there's a medical or psychological
explanation for them and he's also
wondering if Dr Tan you know if anyone
who've experienced similar
events well plus they're hiking in the
mountains there's also less oxygen so we
have oxygen deprivation and the rest of
these combined so what are the
thresholds for hallucination
so I I would imagine many people have
different
um kind of thresholds because when we
think about people who are in the
mountains at high altitude for the
majority of their life they don't
experience the same things you and I do
who come basically from sea level
but you talk about dehydration you
talked about uh oxygen deprivation talk
about calorie deficits all those things
can make you a little loopy but the
concerning thing is especially if it's
hiking at high altitude is brain
swelling cerebral edema so high altitude
cerebral edema which would be a severe
effect of uh being at that altitude so
that can cause some
mental changes as well
um so hopefully that was not the case
and it was just a little dehydrated and
calorie deficit because when we think
about how many calories we need it's on
the scale of over 6 000 kilocalories a
day so
um with altitude sickness feeling
nauseated not having a good appetite
it's very hard to get over 6 000
kilocalories a day in food unless you're
eating straight butter right right and
just to be clear uh a a Food calorie
that would be 6 000 calories but a
physics calorie is six thousand
kilocalories right which is it a Capital
C is six thousand little C's yeah yeah I
just want to clarify that wow so so
there's a a section of the bible where
jesus goes out into the Wilderness for
days and 40 nights I don't remember how
long it might have been that long yeah
is that right and he begins to
hallucinate while he's he's
um he's fasting and so uh so the fasting
would be a trigger but he doesn't call
it hallucinating he's like talking to
God right but you would expect some
neurological shift
in him he didn't say let me go to the
Oasis you know and eat banquet food and
then talk it's like let us stress the
physiology of my body
then I'm susceptible to these kinds of
visions and and that's what happened
there well yeah right on yeah because
um when you're stepping away from
homeostasis in your body whether that's
dehydration calories or temperature so
I'm not sure if Jesus was having some
heat stroke out there that can all
change your mental status and we see
that all the time in the elderly so they
come in you don't really know what's
going on and it just these small ships
that make them have delirium and uh that
would be surprising in those situations
yeah interesting all right let's keep it
going give me another all right let's
Chuck let me jump in on this one um this
is the apocalyptic scenario so prepare
yourselves Emily kaneko Reynolds I hope
I pronounced that correctly she's from
Kyoto in Japan how would you prepare for
a scenario where all the electricity
goes down for the foreseeable future or
all our satellites completely power off
um what would be the top three
relatively easy things to have in place
for survival now
AR-15
make sure you got enough ammunition
that's the first thing you want to do is
go count your bullets
Chuck you're you're not wrong
don't don't don't don't
encourage him
all kinds of things all the things you
need and your body does just have an AR
then that that stuff is his or hers you
know unfortunately that that's the law
of the end of the world right right so
whoever has that power yeah
power control is a huge one so we can
talk about sustainable energy we can
talk about uh food supply for the last
years but uh if there's an overpowering
Force it's not yours anymore
the law at the end of the world why do
you even have that as a phrase
now now you're spooking me a little the
law of the Israel like it's I've got it
up on my wall
do you have enough ammo
enhance your bullets all right
here's an interesting one this is
Kenneth Von smells more very funny
Kenneth indeed indeed sir yes yes he
says greetings from Atlanta Georgia
modern medicine and Technology are
amazing and clearly have improved our
overall Health and Longevity we may not
have access to this in the wild
what primitive methods are just as
effective as modern medicine are there
any that are arguably better I'm
reminded of things like using ants to
suture a cut or maggots to clean a wound
hmm I've heard of maggots I I haven't
heard of suturing ants before but I
would say things very simply
um that you can use in a survival
situation or starvation situation is
natural fibers so one of the biggest
complaint is severe constipation so much
so that we have bowel obstructions and
that could turn to
explosions of your intestines oh yeah
decreasing fiber intake is a very simple
way to do that there are some uh plant
mixtures that can be used as pictures or
anti-microbials but again there's no
head-to-head study so we can't really
say that that's super effective but what
is super effective is removing as much
bacterial load as possible so having a
way to pressure wash with semi-clean
water so it might be boiled and cooled
with a 60 ml syringe typically removes
enough bacterial load if it's not
soaking feces
to let your body heal itself so the
majority of the cut that I personally
get in the field the ones that I got on
alone I just washed it really well with
a pressure watch and let my body heal
right so I wouldn't say it's uh as
effective as antibiotics but it gives
your body a biting chance yeah and
believe it or not that was a big problem
in medicine before you know we started
practicing it the way we we do called
modern medicine it's just things were
not clean
you know it's just just the fact that
things were not clean
um made people die mostly of infection
not not really what what was making them
sick or what the injury was it was the
infection that killed them so
cleanliness is my grandparents said
never go to the hospital because that's
where you go to die and that's what my
grandpa says too it makes sense so so
only in modern times just let me go to
the hospital so I can get better right
so that had to shift over time exactly
yeah dude that's fascinating all right
give me more give me more all right on
the same theme here this is Evan Fenwick
or that might be pronounced fennec we uh
just depends right
this is from Ontario Canada so in your
neighborhood my question is what is the
most effective method to Stave off
infections in the wild and should you
get an infection what is the most
effective way to treat or manage I think
the last bit we've kind of addressed but
um no we haven't because personal
hygiene making sure that you're washing
all of your your things that you're
processing
um so my setup for eating was 100 meters
away from where I was processing uh the
meats and I had
um a few different bins that I would use
to wash my hands you can make them mild
soap because we use a reaction between
uh baits and some fats so whether that's
uh fat from animals or just the grease
in your hair you can make a very mild
Soap by just adding white ash which is a
base and then water and then that grease
you make mild soap with that you say
that like everybody knows that you say
that like so cool yeah yeah let me get
some grease out of my hair
my hair was great out there I I I made
my own little shampoo
man that's crazy great yeah so dude I
don't I don't know if we have any time
left uh yeah all right here we go Neil
got one more Captain
can you really cut off your own limb
wouldn't you just pass out halfway
through and wake up with half a cut off
limp because we know with their cases
like that what the dude wrote a book
between a rock and a hard place yeah
we're here yeah so is that you're a
medically trained survivalist is that
possible
so it is possible but you if you pass
out the main thing to do is to set up a
tourniquet if it is an extremity you
could set up a tourniquet ahead of time
ahead it's a pass out from the pain
you'll pass out but then wake up and
then see what you're doing and then if
you can muscle through it and and uh cut
it through because after a certain
amount of time that stop and blood flow
will affect uh your nerves and then that
nerves may make that area feel numb
another way you can do it is you dunk it
in the cold so you dunk that extremity
in the cold put a tourniquet on it and
then kind of saw that all right okay you
have just given me my new worst
nightmare yeah
you're welcome and he answered I just
saw it off yeah now you're ready to sign
off oh my God all right dude well thank
you for sharing your expertise not
amazing a book learn but Street learned
and Wilderness learned all combined and
uh this is like like it or not this is
what a whole lot of people think the
future needs what do you call it end of
what would you say in the world through
the end of the world end of world rules
yeah I'm you know I'll just I you know
I'll be gone well before then
you might want to keep me alive because
I can tell you where on Earth you are
all right I have that that ability but
otherwise I will go and live with uh
yeah that's what we'll do yeah you're on
our bus to Canada okay man look at you
in a cryo State keep your eye there you
go there you go all right Dr Tan Delight
to have you on StarTalk thanks for your
enthusiasm your candor and sharing your
life experience with us that was great
thanks for having me thank you all right
Chuck Gary always good to have you guys
a pleasure pleasure talk Staying Alive
edition of cosmic queries Neil deGrasse
Tyson here keep looking up that's so
gonna be a meme
laughs
foreign